back here at home as many begin to
prepare their Thanksgiving meal together
around the table this holiday will be
extra special for one family the komenko
family recently arrived from Ukraine and
is quickly adapting to their New Life
Giving Thanksgiving a whole new meaning
my mother take a pumpkin and turkey 31
year old Stanley slav komenko is excited
about his first Thanksgiving meal he and
his family will enjoy in the U.S after
fleeing Ukraine when the war broke out
in America I am feel uh
agreed because
I'm living rationally from Ukrainian and
right now be very terrible situations
and we have a big problem komenko his
wife and his parents came to Las Vegas a
few months ago seeking political Asylum
they say it's been hard leaving
everything behind in exchange for their
safety be very hard for us and
the work
out all life we work in a drilling
company we have our home we have
our friends today this family is opening
their home to 8 news now as they Embrace
their new life in America learning
English while exploring Las Vegas we
first come to strip and see uh Bellagio
in this Survivor oh
we all are crying back inside their home
mom is showing off her cooking skills
and having everyone prepare Ukrainian
dishes while she bakes her first turkey
a special Feast they say in a new
country while embracing their culture is
this day you know very important for us
because we say sales for America